Salut à tous, c'est Pêcheur de Trésors
Aujourd'hui on est à Narbonne, une grande ville
En compagnie des Aimants Cools
Fabrice et Aymeric, vous les reconnaissez surement
On avait film la pêche à Agde et on avait trouvé plein de coffres forts
Logiquement, il va y avoir du lourd aujourd'hui et on va bien s'amuser
Là c'est un de leur coin et il y a déjà du lourd
Ah oui ! Une barrière
Fais attention, il y a un crochet au milieu
Ah ben, je l'ai eu ...
Et m***e, juste je dis de faire attention ...
La première vraie trouvaille
Nickel
Tu sens l'odeur ? L'odeur de Narbonne
Ca sent vraiment la merdasse !
Alors, vous le sortez ce vélo ?
Je vais essayer d'envoyer un troisième aimant
Très lourd, il est vieux
Pour un vélo, oui
Bien joué
Bon, on vous le laisse celui-là les gars
Merci ...
C'est un vélo
Aymeric a repéré un vélo et l'a rapproché juste au bord
Deuxième vélo de la journée, celui là a l'air plus récent
C'est un VTT si je ne dis pas de bétise
Un vélo de ville oui
Rockrider, Decathlon
Ok, bien joué
Il y a encore l'anti vole
On t'a montré le vélo en carbone qu'on a trouvé ?
Ouais, magnifique
Le propriétaire nous a dit de le garder
Regardez le leurre de pêche qui était accroché
Aymeric, avec ça tu vas nous attraper quoi ?
Du silure
Du silure haha
Qu'est-ce que tu nous fais ?
Je crois que c'est un mètre
Un mètre en bon état
On a trouvé pas mal des mètres
Ouais c'est un objet typique que les gens font tomber quand ils travaillent
Ca ne serait pas une météorite ? Un cailloux aimanté
Celle là, je la garde dans la poche
Nos petits poteaux préférés de Narbonne
C'est vrai qu'ils sont sympa ceux là
Voilà, avec un petit leurre
Il est jolie en plus
Ceux là on les aimes, lourd et ils ne prennent pas de place
C'est clair !
Ah ! J'ai quelque chose
Un pédalier ouais
Ils aiment les pédaliers ici
Tu en a trouvé un autre juste tout à l'heure
Là j'ai trouvé une belle pièce
Il y a un aigle dessus
C'est bon signe, non ?
il s'agit d'un rouble russe
Reconnaissable grâce à son aigle de la banque de Russie
Un rouble c'est environ 1,2 centime d'euro
Là les gars regardez, une bouteille de protoxyde d'azote
Un classique aussi
Il y en a des choses ici !
Alors, qu'est-ce que c'est tout cela ?
Oh ! C'est une machette
Ah ouais. - Mais elle est cassée
On peut récupérer le bois
Il n'a pas l'air d'être de très bonne qualité
En tout cas elle a été pliée
Ouais je sais pas, c'est bizarre elle n'a pas l'air si vieille
Elle a des dents à la base
L'autre objet c'est un ancien fer à repasser
Un fer à repasser en fonte
Ah ben, la poignée a cassée ...
Voilà la Police Municipale, c'est les collègues
Un cadenas ouvert, si vous voulez faire une blague a quelqu'un
Qu'est-ce que c'est ça ? Un panneau ?
C'est un couvercle pour les gros plats
Pour les plats de la cantine
C'est génial, les gros plats pour le four
Il y a encore l'étiquette, regardes
Voilà ce bel endroit, dans Narbonne
Avec le château de Narbonne
C'est le centre historique
Il y a un poème sur les murs de la ville mais je suis trop myope pour pouvoir vous le lire
Je crois que j'ai un objet qui ne me plait pas trop
Non, non
Ah non, c'est bon
Des roues de skate ?
De rollers, patinettes
Ca ressemble à un coffre fort mais ce n'est pas un
C'est un appareil électrique
Il a prit cher
Ouais il n'est pas jeune
Marque "Antique"
On aurait dit un petit coffre enroulé dans du fils
Voyons ce qu'on trouve avec cet aimant, dans ce canal
Moi aussi j'ai eu quelque chose qui est en train de venir
Le fameux !
C'est lourd !
Ah ! C'est bon ça !
C'est ici que tu as dis qu'il y en avait plein
Aymeric est de nouveau sur son objet
J'ai aussi ramené mon aimant pour essayer de l'accrocher aussi
Est-ce que ca ne serait pas cet objet que l'on voit ?
On voit comme une forme
Je suis aussi dessus, c'est vachement lourd
Tu peux nous donner un coup de main Quentin ?
Ok, il se soulève
Une trottinette ?
C'est une énorme barrière en fonte
Elle va nous faire le dos ...
1,2,3
Attend, stop, stop
Bien joué
On dirait un revolver Lefaucheux
Joli
Oui c'est un Lefaucheux
En plus c'est pratique, à l'époque ils avaient prévu une fonctionnalité
Il y a un moyen de raccourcir le canon
Ah ouais
Il est totalement mort
C'est très pratique
Sympa les gars
Oui, bien joué
Très beau, très beau
J'ai déjà fait un comme celui là
Les plaquettes étaient intactes et pourtant le métal était pourri
Oui , c'est du bois d'ébène
Pareil avec le Lefaucheux que l'on a restauré
Bon, il était en meilleur état que celui là
Regardez comme le bois résiste bien à l'eau
Celui là est dans l'eau depuis plus de 100 ans
Je pense que j'ai encore un plot
On va le ramener
Oh non
Attend, tu ne vas pas la remonter tout seul
Elle est coincée dans le mur
Elle est lourde
Ca fait du bien
Alors ?
Une pille
Pas mal
C'est une bite d'amarrage ça
Parfait en terme de poids
Ils ne peuvent plus rien en faire dans cet état
Non, clairement pas
Alors, qu'est-ce que c'est Baptiste ?
Je viens de remonter ça
On dirait un peu un fourreau
Il y a comme des sangles et on dirait un manche
Ouvre le
Faut envoyer un deuxième aimant je pense, derrière
Ah ! C'est un panneau
J'essaie là bas
Attention à l'anneau en fer
30 km/h
Ah il est lourd !
Sacré morceau
Vu la taille des panneaux il y a de quoi faire une table avec ça
Super
Bien joué les gars
Petite fusée éclairante de bateau
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Tu vois ceux là sont très massifs
1,2,3
Attention aux doigts
Encore une belle bête
Bien joué les gars encore
Oh oh !
Oh mais cette chance !
incroyable
La chance est avec toi ! Deuxième
ben alors ?!
Je suis sûr que t'en as trouvé plus que nous en tout
C'est mon fils mon aimant !
Quand il est là t'es sûr d'en trouver !
Attention il y a la caméra juste au dessus
Bon ils ne diraient rien de toute façon
Oui il est fichus
Il y a le chargeur
Il n'est pas restaurable
Mais c'est une belle découverte, bravo
Après expertise le pistolet repêché par Fabrice est un pistolet CZ 27
C'est un pistolet d'origine Tchécoslovaque quand un premier temps
Après l'occupation du pays l'armée allemande s'est mise à en produire elle-même
Cet exemplaire là en fait partie puisqu'il est poinçonné avec une croix gammée et l'aigle allemand
C'est donc une pièce avec une importante valeur historique
Bien entendu elle est neutralisée
Là regarde, c'est quoi ça qui vient ?
Une corde ?
Un grappin ?
magnifique
C'est un ancien grappin
On en a trouvé un comme ça dans le fleuve Orb
Il est attaché à quelque chose
regarde
Deuxième fer à repasser ancien
Pas mal
Fabrice a trouvé deux armes et moi deux fer à repasser
Oui mais là les deux sont aussi dangereux l'un que l'autre
Enfin le fer à repasser est même davantage dangereux
ne bouge pas
Parfait comme ça
Ouais là
C'est bizarre
Attention à tes doigts
c'est impossible
Sinon on tire à plusieurs
C'est étonnant, en tout cas la corde tient le coup
Ou alors il y a un grappin des deux côtés
C'est assez mystérieux, le grappin est à l'envers car il est du côté libre de la corde
On se demande ce qui peut-être accroché à l'autre extrémité de cet corde et ce grappin
Un pronostic ?
Moi je pense que c'est juste le bout de la corde qui est accroché dans des choses au fond
Ouais mais à ce point là ?
1,2,3
la corde va lâcher au bout d'un moment
Il y a un bus qui arrive en plus
la mobylette bleue
Peugeot 103
Elle est bien bloquée la corde
Attention à l'anneau
La peinture est encore belle
Elle est remplie de vase
Mais oui le bleu est toujours superbe
Bien joué
regardez ce que j'ai trouvé
C'est un appât
ça ne date pas de la guerre ça
Ce doit être un détonateur de grenade lacrymogène ou d'entraînement
pas vieille pas vieille...
Je ne pense pas que ça date de la seconde guerre mondiale
Non peut-être pas
mais c'est vieux quand même
Le détonateur est encore présent
Oui faites gaffe
Dommage que le grappin soit coincé là bas
Il est peut-être accroché à un mat
ouais c'est possible
Parfois ils accrochent leurs petites barques à ce type de mats avec des grappins
parfait comme ça on ne laisse rien sur place
de toute façon le panneau n'aurait jamais été remis en place il est trop abîmé
Il ira à la ferraille
Voilà
Un demi panneau
Elle est claire l'eau qui sort
On pourrait presque la boire
Voilà le résultat de la pêche
pour cette matinée bien chargée
Et si ça vous a plus on ferra une partie 2
Avec Fabrice et Aymeric, les aimants cools
Et Rasta sera là aussi parce que là le pauvre on ne le voyait pas dans cette vidéo
Bah si il était là mais il dormait
On sort du lourd à chaque fois !